اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرضون معكم ابرز المستجدات وفي
العناوين
20 ملفا يبحثها وزراء الخارجيه العرب ابرز
اعاده اعمار سوريا ووقف الحرب في السودان
اوروبا تعتزم بناء تحالف تقوده بريطانيا
وهولندا لتزويد اوكرانيا بمقاتلات من طراز
بعد اقاله باشاغه واحالته للتحقيق
البرلمان الليبي يقول ان حكومته في
بتعهدتها
وسط اطلاق نار كثيف قوات اسرائيليه تقتحم
مدينه طوباس شمال الضفه واصابات بين
الفلسطينيين
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا البدايه من مدينه جده
حيث يجتمع وزراء الخارجي العرب اليوم
تحضير لاعمال قمه القاده العرب في جده
وتتسلم السعوديه رئاسه القمه من الجزائر
ويتناول جدول اعمال القمه 20 ملفا رئيسيا
لمختلف قضايا العام العربي المشترك وفي
مقدمتها الازمه السودانيه وجهود الوساطه
لوضع حل لتلك الازمه وملف اعاده اعمار
سوريا وعوده حي الجامعه العربيه كما يناقش
الاجتماع الوزاري مشروعات القرارات التي
ستعرض على القاده العرب في اجتماع القمه
يوم الجمعه لاقرارها
تتزامن قيمه جدا مشاهدينا مع احداث مهمه
ابرزها عوده سوريا الى الجامعه العربيه
والتصعيد الاسرائيلي في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه والازمه في السودان وقال
السفير حسام زكي الامين العام المساعد
للجامعه العربيه ان الملف السودانيه
سيتصدر ملفات القمه وسيبحث وزراء الخارجيه
قبيل القمه كيفيه التحرك قدما لتحقيق وقف
مستمر لاطلاق النار ولفت السفير حسام زكي
لانه بالاضافه للسودان هناك ملفات سياسيه
مهمه تاتي في مقدمتها فلسطين كذلك قضيه
اعاده اعمار سوريا وعودتها الى الجامعه
العربيه بعد 12 عاما يلغيها ورحب الامين
العام المساعد باتفاق السعودي الايراني
مشيرا الى انه سينعكس ايجابا على
الاستقرار في المنطقه
يتطورات الحرب الاوكرانيه مشاهدينا حيث
اكد رئيس الوزراء البريطاني كان لندن
تعتزم بناء تحالف دولي لتزويد اوكرانيا
بطائرات مقاتله بطراز 16 وذلك
التاكيد على ان المكان الصحيح لاوكرانيا
هو في حلف شمال الاطلسي هو اشار بيان
للحكومه البريطانيه ان رئيسي الوزراء
البريطاني والهولندي اتفقا على اهميه ان
يزود الحلفاء اوكرانيا بمساعده امنيه
طويله الامد لضمان قدرتها على ربع هجمات
مستقبليه
بعد ايام بتسالمها صواريخ بعيده المدى من
بريطانيا اكد مسؤولان امريكيان واخر غربي
ان اوكرانيا بدات استخدام هذه الصواريخ ضد
اهداف الروسيه دون تحديدها بحسم اخرته
شبكه سي ان ان هذا يشير خبراء الى ان
اوكرانيا تعول على الصوم شادو من اجل
هزيمه القوات الروسيه في الهجوم المضاد
المقبل اذا تعتقد انها قادره على تغيير
الموازين العسكريه على الارض كما تخطط
اوكرانيا لاستعمال هذه الصواريخ لمهاجمه
مراكز القياده الروسيه وخطوط الامداد
والذخيره ومستودعات الوقود في شبه جزيره
القرم والاراضي التي تسيطر عليها روسيا في
الشرق
هذا وقال مسؤول امريكي لشبكه دي سي ان ان
احد انظمه الدفاع الجوي تعرض لاضرار لكن
لم يتم تدميره وذلك بعد هجوم صاروخي
قرباكي وقال المسؤولان انه واشنطن لا تزال
تقيم حجم الضرر الذي اصاب النظام
على الجانب الاخر مشاهدينا اكدت مصادر
العربيه ان وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
لاي ضرر وان جميع الصواريخ الروسيه تم
اسقاطها في الهواء قبل وصولها الى اهدافها
في كييف ومحيطها ايضا نتابع بعد اعلان من
احد المسؤولين
الامريكيين عن تعرض او تضرر احدى منظومات
باكال نفت وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه بشكل
ممتام عبر نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني ان
مليار الذي صرحت لاحلى الوسائل الاعلام
الاوكرانيه وايضا في تدوين عبر تويتر نفر
ان تكون تعرضت اي منظومه جويه ليس فقط اي
منظومه
جويه لاي
اضرار اهداف التي تم اسقاطها على مراه
سكان العاصمه الاوكرانيه تم اصابتها
جميعها في الهواء ولم يكن هناك سقوط اي
صاروخ على اي هدف في محيط او في مقاطعه
ايام او حتى فوق او في العاصمه الاوكرانيه
اكدت اوكرانيا انها استعادت من القوات
الروسيه 20 كيلومترا مربعا في محيط بخموت
المحاصره في شرق البلاد حيث تدور معارك
شرسه بين الجانبين منذ عده اشهر وقالت
نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني هانا مليار
في بيان قالت ان القوات الروسيه تم
ارغامها عن التخلي بل على التخلي عن اجزاء
من الاراضي المحيط بالمدينه مشيره في
الوقت نفسه الى ان القوات الروسيه تتقدم
داخل باخمت وتقوم بعمليه تدمير واسعه
للمدينه
حول ما جرى منظومه التي تقول موسكو انها
دمرتها او عطلتها في اوكرانيا
مرحبا احمد بالفعل ابدا اولا بوسائل
الاعلام الروسيه التي تداولت منذ الصباح
بان انظمه الامريكيه لم تستطع حتى حمايه
نفسها من الصاروخ كنجال الذي تم استخدامه
يوم امس لقصف هذه المنظومه كان قد اعلنت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عن انها قامت بقصف
هذه المنظومه بصاروخ كنجال والذي تحدث عنه
اليوم منذ الصباح الخبراء العسكريين الذين
قالوا انه تم قصره من مقاتل روسيه 31 كاف
وهذا ما تم تسجيله على بالفيديو وتم نشر
هذا الفيديو في وسائل الاعلام الروسيه
تسجل لحظه انفجار هذه المنظومه بعد ان
قامت باطلاق العديد من الصواريخ ومن ثم
يظهر الفيديو انفجارا كبيرا كبيرا في مكان
هذه المنظومه طبعا كما تحدث الخبراء ايضا
ان صواريخ كانجال
الفارض الفارطه الصوتيه كانت قادره على
تدمير هذه المنظومه لانها قادره للوصول
الى مكان الهدف خلال وقت قصير جدا لذلك لم
تستطع هذه المنظومه بعد اطلاقها لعديد من
الصواريخ ان تقوم بحمايه نفسها واسقاط هذا
هذا الصاروخ هذا ما يتم تداوله احمد منذ
صباح حول هذا هذا الحدث او هذا الهدف الذي
استهدفته القوات الروسيه خلال يوم امس هي
كانت تتشنت فصفا او هجوما مكثفا على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه استهدفت العديد من
المناطق واستهدفت واسقطت نحو 20 طائره
مسيره في اتجاه منطقه خرسون اما ميدانيا
طبعا القوات الروسيه في الباخمه كما وصفه
العديد بانها الان الاوضاع هناك صعبه جدا
التقدم هو بطيء ولكن هناك تقدم للقوات
الروسيه وبالاخص قوات فاقدر الخاصه التي
هي الان موجوده في الشمال
وغرب مدينه اباخت تقوم طبعا وصلت الى
مناطق قريبه من جدا من
المناطق التي يتم وضع فيها القوات
الاوكرانيه في الشمال الشمال الغربي
للمدينه احمد طيب هناك موضه اخرى كاتيا
تعاني منها موسكو وهي مساله الدعم
البريطاني السخي لاوكرانيا كيف تنظر اذا
موسكو لهذا الدعم وما اذا كانت هناك خطط
معلنه للتعاطي مع هذه الاسلحه المقدمه
ايضا
روسيا كانت دائما تتحدث احمد على انها اي
شحنه غربيه لاوكرانيا هي هدف شرعي للقوات
الروسيه وهذا ما نشاهده طبعا دائما خلال
بيانات التي تظهرها وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
بانها تقوم باستهداف اما مستودعات الاسلحه
كانت قد وصلت الى اوكرانيا او حتى يوم امس
منظومه الدفاع الامريكيه التي استهدفتها
ايضا في اوكرانيا وكان قد تحدث
الكرملين على لسان الذي قيم سلبا هذه
الخطوه من قبل لندن بانها تقوم بتاجيج
الوضع على الارض هناك وهذا طبعا ما سيدفع
باولا بخسائر بشريه على الارض كما تقول
دائما موسكو والى اطاله مده العمليه
العسكريه التي تقوم بها ولكن كما تقول
موسك وتكرر دائما بانها ستذهب حتى النهايه
وانها هي ستنتصر في هذه العمليه العسكريه
التي بداتها في اوكرانيا احمد علقت موسكو
على ما ذكرته كيف ان استعاده تعيشين
كيلومترا من بخ في خلال الساعات 24
الماضيه
حقيقه لم تعلق ولكن كما ذكرت لك ان
الاوضاع هناك جدا صعبه كان هناك مرارا
حديث من قبل قوات فاكتر الخاصه بانها
تتقدم ولكن بشكل بطيء وان هناك مقاومه
كبيره جدا من القوات الاوكرانيه هناك بسبب
ايضا وصول الدعم العسكري الى هذه القوات
ولكن حتى الان هناك كان اعاده تجمع للقوات
الروسيه كما تحدث يوم امس رئيس دنيتك
الانفصاليه عن وجود اعاده التجمع للقوات
الروسيه بالاضافه الى تحرك قوات فاقد
الخاصه في شمال وغربي مدينه احمد نعم شكرا
لك من موسكو كنت معنا مراسه العربيه كاتيا
طعمه تحياتي كاتيا
اوكرانيا امام مفترق طرق حاسم في حربها ضد
روسيا
والفرصه قد تكون مواتيه لكييف من اجل حسم
المعركه
صحيفه تايمز البريطانيه الوقت مناسب
لاوكرانيا لتوجيه ضربه موجعه لموسكو فما
هي العوامل التي ترجح كافه
العامل الاول الانقسامات بين الجنرالات
الروس
العامل الثاني تغيير بوتين للقاده
العسكريين على امتداد الحرب
العامل الثالث استنزاف القوات الروسيه في
معركه بخموت
العامل الرابع فشل حملات التجنيد الروسيه
في حسم الحربه
العامل الخامس زياده تدفق اسلحه الغرب الى
اوكرانيا
رصدت الولايات المتحده مكافاه بقيمه عشره
ملايين دولار وذلك لمن يقوم بتزويدهم
المعلومات لايقاف احد القراصنه
الالكترونيين الروس والذي يدعى بميخائيل
حسب وزاره العدل الامريكيه حيث ان الهكر
الروسي كان خلف هجمات سيبرانيه استهدفت
شرطه واشنطن ومدارس ومستشفيات في الولايات
المتحده وقالت وزاره العد الامريكيه في
بيان الى ميخائيل متهم باستخدام برامج في
دياب البرامج
لمهاجمه اهداف في الولايات المتحده
انطلاقا من روسيا بقصد الحصول من ضحاياه
على فديات ماليه تصل قيمتها الاجماليه الى
200 مليون دولار
اعتبر وزير الدفاع الامريكي انما وصفه
بالغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا والطريقه التي
تقوم فيها كييف التي تقاوي فيها كييف قوه
موسكو يقدمان درسا قيما لتايوان اذ يبينان
كيفيه ان يمكن لجيش اصغر ان يتصدى لاخر
اكبر وخلال جلسه استماع امام لجنه بمجلس
الشيوخ وبفضل الدعم الكبير الذي حصلت عليه
لم تمنع اوكرانيا القوات الروسيه من
احتلالها فحسب بل استعادت قسما من الاراضي
التي استولت عليها قوات موسكو في الايام
الاولى للهجوم
كشف الكريم من ان موسكو لم تحدد موقفها
لجهه تمديد اتفاق البحر الاسود الذي يضمن
تصدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه الى مختلف اقاليم
العالم وبحسب المتحدث باسم بيسكوب ما زالت
روسيا تملك اسئله حول هذا الاتفاق نتابع
يطرق الجوع مجددا ابواب ملايين البشر مع
تزايد مخاوف عدم تمديد اتفاق البحر الاسود
والذي يضمن تصدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه الى
العالم الاتفاق الذي يضم روسيا واوكرانيا
وتركيا وترعاه الامم المتحده تنتهي
صلاحيته في الثامن عشر من مايو في حال فشل
التجديد بالتزامن مع التلويح الروسي
بتعليقه انهاء الاتفاق يضرب اوكرانيا سله
العالم الغذائيه والتي اصلا تاثر قطاعها
الزراعي بطبيعات القصف الروسي فتراجعت
محاصيلها الى ادنى مستويات لها منذ عقد
انقر والامم المتحده فشلت بالحصول على
ضمانات تجديد الاتفاق فيما يستمر تقاذف
التهم بين موسكو حول الجهه المسؤوله عن
الازمه
انه امر مثير للاشمئزاز ان تتظاهر روسيا
انها الجانب الخاسر في الاتفاق ولن اذكر
المجلس بعدم اخلاقيه مثل هذه الشكاوى من
المعتديه والتي كانت ولا تزال التهديد
الوحيد لشحنات الغذاء في البحر الاسود
حذرنا من اننا لا نستطيع المضيف الاتفاق
ان لم تتم معالجه القضايا التي تعيق
امدادات القطاع الزراعي الروسي تسعى الامم
المتحده الى دعم روسيا لتحقيق مطالبها
وانقاذ الاتفاق فموسكو تربط المضي
بالاتفاق بازاله كل العراقيل امام
صادراتها من الحبوب والاسمده الى ذلك
تطالب باستئناف خط الانابيب الذي ينقل
الامونيا الروسيه الى موانئ اوكرانيا
بالاضافه الى رفع القيود المفروضه على
المدفوعات والخدمات اللوجستيه والتامين
المرتبطه بالشحنات فضلا عن اعاده ربط
البنك الزراعي الروسي بنظام سويفت العالمي
للدفع
غادرت اخر السفن الغذائيه موانئ اوكرانيا
بموجب الاتفاق ليصل بذلك الى نهايته عمليا
الا ان محاولات احيائه تستمر لاسيما مع
تضاعف المخاوف على مستقبل القطع الزراعي
الاوكراني بسبب تاثيرات القصف والالغام
على خصوبه الاراضي الزراعيه الاوكرانيه
مشاهدينا بالعوده مره اخرى الى اعمال
القمه العربيه في جده ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه عبد الرحمن العصيمي اهلا بك عبد
الرحمن ومتى تصدق ستبدا اعمال اجتماع
وزراء الخارجيه العرب في جده وما ابرز
الملفات التي ستناقش ايضا على طاوله هذه
المناقشات
نعم في القاعه التي تشاهدونها خلفي ستشهد
ثلاث كلمات مرتقبه ربما بعد ساعه من الان
الكلمه الاولى لوزير الخارجيه الجزائريه
الذي سيسلم
القمه لوزير الخارجيه السعودي الذي بدوره
ايضا سيلقي كلمه ومن ثم كلمه للامين العام
لجامعه الدول العربيه طبعا قبل الاجتماع
وزراء الخارجيه العرب هناك اجتماعات لجان
وزاريه معنيه بعده ملفات في المنطقه
العربيه هناك اربعه اجتماعات الاجتماع
الاول هو للجنه الوزاريه العربيه الرباعيه
التي تعنى
بالنقاش حول التدخلات الايرانيه في
المنطقه العربيه وسبل التصدي لها ايضا
هناك اجتماع للجنه الوزاريه العربيه
المعنيه بمتابعه التدخلات التركيه في
المنطقه العربيه ايضا الاجتماع الثالث
سيكون للجنه الوزاريه العربيه المع بدعم
عضويه دوله فلسطين طبعا هي لجنه مفتوحه
وتعقد في كل اجتماع وزراء خارجيه في القمم
العربيه الماضيه واخيرا هناك اجتماع للجنه
الوزاريه المكلفه بدراسه القرارات
والتوصيات المنبثقه من القمه الماضيه قمه
الجزائر واقتراحات الرئيس الجزائري عبد
المجيد تبون ومن ثم سيعقد وزراء الخارجيه
العرب اجتماعاتهم هذه القمه المرتقبه التي
تحمل الكثير من الملفات الساخنه والتحديات
الاقليميه على راسها ملف الازمه السودانيه
الى جانب ايضا عوده سوريا الى الحضن
العربي ومتابعه دمجها اكثر فاكثر في
محيطها العربي الى جانب ايضا هناك
ملف السلام في اليمن وايضا استكمال
الاتفاق السعودي اليمني وضمان
العمليه السياسيه والح في اليمن الى جانب
ايضا ملف الامن الغذائي لا سيما في ظل
الازمه الروسيه الاوكرانيه وايضا ملف
الامن المائي لسيما هناك مشكله بين
السودان ومصر مع اثيوبيا فيما يتعلق بسد
النهضه وايضا العراق وسوريا مع
جارتهما تركيا بالاضافه طبعا الى الملف
اللبناني الملف الفلسطيني وايضا الملف
الليبي وموضوع الانتخابات الرئاسيه هناك
وعمليه الحوار السياسي المستمر ومحاوله
ايجاد حل الخلافات الليبيه الليبيه
الداخليه فمن المنتظر ان تكون هذه القمه
تاريخيه اولا بعدد الزعماء والرؤساء
والملوك المشاركين المتوقع ان يحضر الكثير
منهم على خلاف
في سياق استقبال هؤلاء القاده العربي يعني
ما الذي متابعه
في الوصول وما الذي عد ايضا من ترتيبات
الاستقبالهم في جده
الانباء حتى الان تقول بان الوفود ستصل
على مدار يومين يوم غدا الخميس مساء سيصل
بعض الوفود والزعماء وايضا يوم الجمعه
صباحا حتى 12 ظهرا بتوقيت جده سيصل اخر
ومن ثم من المتوقع ان تعقد القمه العربيه
ظهر يوم الجمعه طبعا حتى الان لم يحدد
الوقت بالضبط لكن ستكون مساء يوم الجمعه
بحضور جميع الزعماء وايضا
المرتقب ايضا هو بيان القمه الختامي الذي
سيحمل توصيات عديده وايضا
سيحمل الكثير من الرؤيه فيما يتعلق
بالمنطقه التي تمر بعدد من الازمات
والمشكلات وايضا التحالفات الجديده في ظل
الاوضاع الراهنه سواء على الصعيد الاقليمي
او ايضا الصعيد العالمي فهذه قمه غير
عاديه من المرتقب ان تحمل الكثير من
التوصيات التي تضمن لهذه المنطقه ان تعيش
بسلام وامان خلال الفتره المقبله بوجود
سلام غير معهود بين الدول العربيه واتفاق
على كثير من الرؤى المشتركه بين الدول
الجامعه
لمجريات هذا اليوم شكرا لك من جدا مراسل
العربي عبد الرحمن
مستمرا مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
الامم المتحده تقول ان خطه الاستجابه
الانسانيه للسرعه في السودان تتطلب
ميليارين و6 وخمسين مليون دولار
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد في خضم
الاقتتال
في السودان قال مسؤول كبير المتحده ان خطه
المنظمه الاستجابه الانسانيه في السودان
تتطلب
مليارين وسته وخمسين مليون دولار لمساعده
المتضررين من الازمه هناك وقال رئيس مكتب
الامم المتحده لتنسيق الشؤون الانسانيه
قال اليوم ان السودان يحتاج الى 25 مليون
بل ان هناك 25 مليون شخص يحتاجون الى اكثر
من نصف عدد السكان يحتاجون الى المساعدات
الانسانيه عفوا والحمايه كما توقعات
المتحده ان يبلغ عدد الفارينه من السودان
مليون اللاجئين هذا العام كما اشار مدير
المكتب الامومي لتنسيق الشؤون الانسانيه
الى ان الوضع في السودان يتحول الى ما
وصفه بالازمه الاقليميه بوتيره سريعه
ميدانيا قال الجيش في بيان الى اشتباكات
جرت مع قوات الدعم السريع في شمال مدينه
بحري ووسط الخرطوم نتج عنها بل نتجت عنها
خسائر كبيره في القوات والاسلحه ومركبات
بيان جيش ذكر ان الموقف العمليه مستقر
بعموم البلاد عدا اجزاء من العاصمه بدورها
قوات الدعم السريع اتهمت الجيش بشن هجوم
على مواقعها في الشمال الخرطوم بحري
واوضحت انها استولت على عدد من معسكرات
شمال بحري واعتقلت اكثر من 700 جندي
بالاضافه الى مقتل العشرات
ونبقى في السودان حيث نفت قوات الدعم
السريع تعرض البعثه الدبلوماسيه بالخرطوم
لهجمات مؤكده انها تحت حمايتها قبل ذلك
قال لواء نبيل عبد الله الناطق باسم الجيش
السوداني ان الظروف الحرب منعت قوات الامن
من توفير الحمايه اللازمه لمقر البعثه
دبلوماسيه عبد الله اتهم قوات الدعم
السريع بمهاجمه مقر دبلوماسيه ونهب
ممتلكاتها واتلاف ما فيها بمستندات واضاف
الناطق باسم الجيش السوداني ان ادله اتهام
قوات الدعم السريع بشان تلك الهجمات تستند
الى بلاغات تقدمت بها السفارات فضلا عن
روايات شهود عيان
مشاهدينا الصحفي مقداد حسن اهلا بك مقداد
وهناك كما تبعنا اتهامات واتهامات مضاده
ايضا فيما يتعلق بالاعتداءات على الباحثات
الدبلوماسيه اين تكمن حقيقه ما يجري بحسب
ما توفر لك من معلومات مقداد من الذي
يعتدي ومن الذي يدافع عن هذه المقرات
الدبلوماسيه
اهلا احمد نعم هذه الاعتداءات
وهذه الاتهامات المتبادله شهدناها كثيره
جدا منذ الايام الاولى في ابريل الماضي
وبالتالي فان الجيش السوداني يقول ان
الاعتداءات المتكرره على البعثات
الدبلوماسيه
بشهاده مواطنين وبشهادات موثقه لديه هي من
قوات الدعم السريع وقوات الدعم السريع
ايضا في بيانات متكرره جدا وكثيره تنشر
وتنفي ما نسب اليها وقبل قليل ايضا قد
نشرت فيديوهات تتحدث عن انها امام مقر بيت
السفير السعودي وبالتالي فان هذه
الاتهامات المتبادله تصعب من معرفه
الحقيقه بالضبط لكن الجيش السوداني يؤكد
ان هنالك بعثات دبلوماسيه شكت اليها وان
مواطنين ايضا وشهادات شهود عيان تقول ان
الدعم السريع دائما ما يكرر هذه الاعت
وايضا كثير من الاعتداءات على المنازل
وعلى البنوك وثقتها كاميرات المواطنين
ووثقوها شهود عيان والدعم السريع دائما ما
تنفيه هذه الاتهامات احمد طيب على الصعيد
الميدانيه ايضا مقداد ما ابرز ملامح هذا
اليوم
نعم ميدانيا مدينه درمان تشهد هدوء نسبيا
ليس سوى طائرات استطلاع حلقت في صباح هذا
اليوم وردت اليها بعض المضادات الارضيه في
جنوب وسط ام درمان وكذلك ايضا
سمعت الاشتباكات المتقطعه في وسط الخرطوم
وشمال بحري ميدانيا هذه اللحظات تشهد هدوء
نسبيا خاصه في مدينه ام درمان لكن بموازاه
ذلك هنالك انتشار كثيف للعصابات
والاعتداءات كما ذكرت لك ان هناك اعتداءات
متكرره وبصوره يوميه على البنوك وعلى
المنازل وعلى كذلك
بواسطه عصابات وهذه الانتهاكات ايضا اتهمت
فيها القوات الدعم السريع بصوره متكرره
وسجل شهود عيان كذلك اعتداءات على بنوك
مختلفه في شمال ام درمان وفي السوق الشعبي
بواسطه قوات الدعم السريع قوات الدعم
السريع دائما تنفي هذه الاتهامات ببيانات
متكرره لكن ما شهدناه بانفسنا ان هناك
عصابات للسلب والنهب اصبحت وضح النهار وفي
اوقات متفرقه نسمع بها هنا وهناك تعتدي
على المنازل وتعتدي كذلك على الاسواق
وتعتدي على المواطنين الامنين وكذلك ايضا
شهدنا ان سوق ام درمان طالته ايادي
التخريب بصوره بالغه ومؤسفه للغايه بعد ان
بعد ان يتم بعد ان يتم سلبه ونهب المتاجر
هنالك عمليات حرق واسعه شهدناها في الايام
القلية الماضي وحتى هذه اللحظات نشاهد
الحرائق المتكرره والتي لم نسمع اي
اشتباكات او اي قذائف تسقط على هذه
المباني وانما هي بفعل فاعل كما اكد لنا
شهود عيان وايضا جراء هذه الاشتباكات
المحتدمه هنالك قذائف وهنالك مقذوفات تسقط
عشوائيا على المواطنين بصوره متكرره صباح
هذا اليوم ايضا شهدنا مقذوفات سقطت في
شارع الوادي على احد المخابز ويوم وبالامس
ايضا في مدينه الخرطوم جنوبي جنوب الخرطوم
حي الكويت هنالك ايضا مقذوفات ادت الى
سقوط واحده من
المعارف الذين نعرفها في جراء هذه
الاشتباكات في بالامس التي كانت محتدمه
جدا في شارع 61 بالعمارات وبالتالي فان
التكلفه تزداد يوما بعد يوم على المواطن
الذي يعيش داخل محيط هذه الاشتباكات وداخل
مدينه الخرطوم وهذا منعكس بصوره واضحه على
عمليات النزوح وعمليات الفرار من الوجه
الاخر للحرب الذي يعاني منه المواطن في
عموم المدن الثلاث شكرا لك على كل هذه
المعلومات والتفاصيل ينظر ما كنت معنا
الصحفي مقداد حسن تحياتي
في الازمه الليبيه مشاهدينا بعد اقاله
رئاسه الحكومه المكلفه في ليبيا اوضح
المتحدث الرسمي باسم مجلس النواب الليبيه
عبد الله بلحق ان حكومه فتح باشاغه التي
تشكلت العام الماضي بتكليف مجلس النواب
فشلت في الوفاء بتعهدتها كما اشار الى ان
باشاغا لم ينفذ عوده في وفي مقدمتها ايضا
العمل من داخل العاصمه طرابلس نتابع قرر
مجلس النواب
ايقاف السيد
رئيس الحكومه سيد فتحي باش اغا واحالته
للتحقيق
والتكليف السيد وزير الماليه الدكتور
اسامه حماد
بمهام رئاسه الحكومه الى حين انتهاء
التحقيقات في مع السيد رئيس الحكومه الامر
متعلق بعدم الوفاء بتعهداتها وتعهدات
السيد رئيس الحكومه في مقدمتها تعهداته
بعمل الحكومه من داخل العاصمه طرابلس
ودخول العاصمه طرابلس وهذا اول تعهد لم
تفي به الحكومه او لم يتحقق ايضا عدم
تحقيق البرامج التي تعاهدت الحكومه بها
فبالتالي هذه هي
النقاط التي ادت الى ايقاف السيد رئيس
الحكومه
وتعليقا على مساله الانتخابات البرلمانيه
اكد المتحدث الرسمي باسم مجلس ان قانون
انتخابات رئيس الدوله او انتخابات مجلس
النواب
انتخابات مجلس النواب
اوفى بكل الالتزامات الملقاه على عاتقه
لا سيما
اصدار القاعده الدستوريه من خلال التعديل
الدستوري الثالث عشر الذي اصدره مجلس
النواب وايضا
[موسيقى]
التوافق عليه والاتفاق عليه مع مجلس
الدوله وهو نافذ ايضا فيما يتعلق في
قوانين الانتخابات قانون انتخابات رئيس
الدوله او قانون انتخاب مجلس النواب مجلس
النواب اصدر هذه القوانين سلفا وكنا قاب
قوسين وادى من اجراء الانتخابات في ديسمبر
وقبيله هذا الموعد بقليل ظهرت قوه قاهره
مثل ما اعلن رئيس المفوضيه هي من عرقله
الانتخابات
العربيه عن اصابه سته فلسطينيين برصاص
الحي والمعدني المغلف بالمطاط بالمطاط
وذلك خلال اقتحام الجيش الاسرائيلي
والمستوطين مقام يوسف شرقي مدينه نابلس
كما كان الجيش الاسرائيلي يعتقل ليله
الماضيه 15 فلسطينيين من انحاء متفرقه في
ضفه الغربيه والقدس الشرقيه
خالد القاسم اهلا بك خالد وضعنا في صوره
المشهد في نابلس هل ما زال الوضع كما هو
عليه
لا انتهت عمليه الاقتحام ليلا حيث قامت
قوات كبيره من الجيش الاسرائيلي بتامين
الحمايه لعشرات المستوطنين الذين دخلوا
الى منطقه
مقام يوسف وادو طقوسا التلموديه في المكان
طبعا لا تخلو اقتحامات الجيش والمستوطنين
من مواجهات واشتباكات مسلحه بينهم وبين
الفلسطينيين حيث اسفلت هذه الاشتباكات عن
اصابه سته فلسطينيين بحسب وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه واختناق اكثر من 80 فلسطينيين
باستنشاق الغاز المسيل للدموع ثم في ساعات
الفجر الاولى انسحب الجيش الاسرائيلي
والمستوطنين من مدينه نابلس واعاده الحياه
الى طبيعتها وليس بعيدا عن نابلس كان هناك
في مدينه طوباس الى
الشمال من مدينه نابلس ايضا دخول قوات
خاصه الى المدينه تم اكتشافه امرها وجرت
مواجهات واشتباكات مسلحه مع التعزيزات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه التي دخلت لتامين
الحمايه للقوات الخاصه الهلال الاحمر
ووزاره الصحه لم تنشر اي بيان حول اذا ما
كان هناك اصابات في مدينه طوباس كما جرت
مواجهات في عده نقاط تركزت في محيط مدينه
رام الله ومحيط محافظه الخليل
جميع هذه الاجتياحات
والاقتحامات للمدن الفلسطينيه غالبا ما
تنفذ
لاعتقال فلسطينيين غالبا ما تتهمهم
اسرائيل بتنفيذ عمليات مسلحه ضد الجيش
الاسرائيلي او المستوطنين تركزت في ثلاث
مناطق رام الله والخليل والجنين ايضا شكرا
لكنت معنا مراسل العربيه خارج القاسم
تحياتي خالد
مشاهدينا ادعى الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان الناخبين الاتراك الى دعمه في
جوله الاعاده من انتخابات الرئاسه في 28
من مايو الجاري من اجل الحفاظ على استقرار
في تركيا في الوقت الذي يسعى فيه لتمديد
حكمه الى عقد ثالث وقال اردوغان ان تركيا
بحاجه الى الانسجام بين البرلمان والرئاسه
من اجل حكم فعال واضاف ان الوجود القوي
للتحالف الشعب في البرلمان سيجعل حكومته
اقوى وان التناغم بين السلطتين التنفيذيه
والتشريعيه سيساعد في تنميه البلاد
اعلنا مرشح الرئاسه التركيه الذي حل ثالثا
في الدوره الاولى من الانتخابات انه منفتح
على الحوار مع كل المرشحين للدوره الثانيه
وفي مقابله
قال اوغان الذي لا ينتمي الى اي حزب سياسي
انه سيتخذ القرار المناسب بتوجيه ناخبيه
لدعم اردوغانو بعد محادثات سيجريها مع
الطرفين وجدد اوجان تاكيده على انه يؤيد
اعتماد موقف حازم من القضيه الكرديه
ويعارض الارهاب بجميع اشكاله
فاصل بين جولتين انتخابيتين في تركيا لا
مجال فيه للاستراحه بل سيكونان الاسبوعين
الاكثر مشقه لطرفي المنافسه للوصول الى
الاغلبيه المطلوبه للفوز
[تصفيق]
نفس قومي يضغى في تركيا متجليا في نتائج
الانتخابات فبالرغم من تقدم تحالف اردوغان
على المعارضه ذات الطابع القومي الا ان
المحللين ووسائل الاعلام باختلاف توجهاتها
اتفقت على ان الاحزاب القوميه حتى تلك
التي لم تكن ضمن ائتلاف المعارضه استطاعت
ان تترك بصمه واضحه في نتائج الانتخابات
ان احدى النتائج الاكثر لفتا للانتباه في
انتخابات هذا العام هي بلا شك صعود اصوات
القوميين من النتائج المهمه الاخرى
للانتخابات ثقل الناخبين القوميين في
المعادلات السياسيه
اما الخلاف في الاوساط الاعلاميه
والسياسيه في تركيا فهو حول دوري اصوات
سنان اوغان مرشح تحالف الاجداد القومي
والذي حصل على خمسه في المئه من الاصوات
وفي مصلحه اي طرف ستصب تلك الاصوات بعد
خروجه من السباق الانتخابي وان كانت ستغير
شيئا من النتيجه
اوغان سيستخدم مليونين وثمانمائه الف صوت
حصل عليها وذلك للتفاوض مع المرشحين الذين
ترك للجوله الثانيه
لا ينبغي لاحد الاعتقاد بان الاصوات
المدلى بها لسنان اجان هي اصوات صلبه
تمسكين بالمحاوله الاخيره يدعو داعم
المعارضه الى جذب اصوات مرشح حزب البلد
القومي محرم انجاح الذي انسحب قبل ايام من
الانتخابات بينما يرى اخرون ان نتيجه
محسومه اصلا لصالح اردوغان طاقه محرم انجي
يجب احضارها الى تحالف الامه اذا كان ذلك
ممكنا
اردوغان سيذهب الى الجوله الثانيه بثلاث
مزايا على الاقل هي الاغلبيه في البرلمان
والمركز الاول في انتخابات الرئاسه الاولى
والتقدم الواضح
نقطه واحده تلعب على نتيجه الجوله القادمه
وهي اصوات القوميين المنسحبين من السباق
الانتخابي والذين لا يفضلون ايا من
المرشحين الحاليين ومن جهه اخرى محاوله
اردوغان لكسب اصوات الاكراد في اسطنبول
الى عمر العربيه
في متابعات محاكمه حفيد حسن البنا مؤسس
مؤسس تنظيم الاخوان طارق رمضان شدد النائب
العام السويسري على ثبات اخواء المدعيه
وتقييم الاطباء النفسيين للواقع بصفتها
عمليه اغتصاب حيث طلب النائب العام الاول
ادريان في جنابه انزال عقوبه الحبس لمده
ثلاث سنوات بينها ثمانيه عشر شهرا مع وفي
التنفيذ بحق رمضان بتهمه الاغتصاب في قضيه
تعود لعام 2008 معتبرا ان طارق رمضان تصرف
بدافع تلبيه رغبته الجنسيه مع امراه
استخدامها كغرض على حد وصفه
نشاطنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
رئيس شاهد
مخاوفه نعم قد يضر العالم
عشرون ملفا يبحثها وزراء خارجيه العرب
ابرزها اعاده اعمار سوريا ووقف الحرب في
السودان
اوروبا تعتزم بناء تحالف تقوده بريطانيا
وهولندا لتزويد اوكرانيا بمقاتلات من طراز
اف 16
الوفاء بتاع بعد اقاله باشاغه واحالته
للتحقيق البرلمان الليبي يقول ان حكومته
لم تفي بتعهدتها
وسط اطلاق نار كثيف قوات اسرائيليه تقتحم
مدينه طوباس شمال الضفه واصابات بين
الفلسطينيين
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد مع اقتراب
الانتخابات الامريكيه 2024 بردت مخاوف من
تاثير الذكاء الاصطناعي على مسارها حيث
قال رئيس التنفيذ للشركه اوبن
وهي الشركه التي كانت خلف اصدار روبورت
الدردشه قال امام لجنه بمجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي ان استخدام الذكاء الصناعيه
التدخل في نزاهه الانتخابات مبعث قلق كبير
مضيفا ان الامر يحتاج الى
تنظيمان على ضروره وضع قواعد وارشادات
توجيهيه للحد من استخدامه للتاثير على
الانتخابات من جانبه قال سيناتور
لا توجد طريقه لحبس هذا المارد في قنينه
في اشاره منه الى الذكاء الاصطناعي مؤكده
انه بمثابه انفجار على مستوى العالم
وفي تداعيات تفاقم ازمه الدين الامريكيه
التي بدات تضغط على اداره بعيد قال متحدث
باسم البيت الابيض لشبكه قال ان الاداره
لا تخطط حاليا لمطالبه الكونجرس بتمويل
جديد لدعم اوكرانيا قبل نهايه السنه
الماليه في سبتمبر المتحدث باسم البيت
الابيض مشاهدينا استدرك بالقول انه يتوقع
ان تكون الموارد كافيه حتى نهايه السنه
الماليه في الولايات المتحده مضيفا ان
واشنطن ستقيم الاوضاع وتحدد ما اذا كانت
تحتاج الى موارد اضافيه لدعم اوكرانيا في
الخريف المقبل
قرر رئيس الامريكي جو بايدن اختصار جوله
كان مقررا ان يقوم بها في اسيا هذا
الاسبوع لاجراء مفاوضات بالغه الاهميه مع
الجمهوريين لتفادي تخلف كارثي محتمل عن
سداد الدين
مسار العمل للتاكد من ان الولايات المتحده
لا تتخلف عن سداد ديونها لاول مره فوفقا
لوكاله للتصنيف الائتماني فان اقتصادنا
سيصبح في حاله ركود وما يقرب من ثمانيه
ملايين امريكي سيفقدون وظائفهم في حال
حصول ذلك لقد اوضحت في اجتماع اليوم ان
التخلف عن السداد ليس خيارا ولا ينبغي ان
تمنع الخلافات السياسيه بين الاحزاب
الكونجرس من ايثاء الولايات المتحده
بالتزاماتها فلم يسبق لنا ان تخلفنا عن
سداد ديوننا ولن نفعل ذلك ابدا
زعماء الكونجرس الى البيت الابيض للتفاوض
على رفع سقف الدين العام الامريكي وبدا
الحزب الديمقراطي مصرا على لوم الجمهوريين
في تعثر الطرفين في الوصول الى اتفاق
المجموعه الوحيده في واشنطن التي تهدد
بالتخلف عن دفع الديون هي النواب
الجمهوريين اما الجمهوريون فوجهوا لومهم
الى الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن واتهموه
بالتغيب عن المحادثات يوم ما دفع الامور
الى سفير الهاويه
على الرئيس ان يقدم افكارا محدده ان لم
يكن مقترحا في الكونغرس
تبدو هذه القضيه سياسيه بامتياز
فالجمهوريون يلومون الاداره الامريكيه على
رفضها التفاوض وخفض المصروفات نتسبب بتضخم
ديون الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وهي
تتخطى الان عتبه 31 تريليون دولار اما
الديمقراطيون فيلومون الجمهوريين بالتسبب
بازمه وربما انهيار دولار واسواق الاسهم
ومدخرات الامريكيين ومعاشاتهم وربما يكون
الامر صحيحا لو فشلت المفاوضات بين
الطرفين في اخر الشهر
اولا تخفض وكالات التصنيف ترتيب الولايات
المتحده ويتبع ذلك دفع الدوله فائده اعلى
على الديون وايضا بعض الناس لن يتسلموا
مدفوعاتهم في حينها وستكون هناك فوضى حول
افضليه وتوقيت الدفع
لكنه لا يتوقع ان تحصل كل هذه الامور دفعه
واحده بل يبقى الامريكيون على مسافه
اسبوعين من لحظه تقول فيها الخزانه
الامريكيه انها ستتوقف عن الدفع
وقد انتهى اجتماع البيت الابيض بالاتفاق
على متابعه المفاوضات
لدينا مهله 15 يوما لايجاد وسيله لخفض
الصرف ورفع مستوى الدين وتحسين الاقتصاد
وهكذا يبقى الاقتصاد الامريكي على شفير
الهاويه
وسيضطر الرئيس الامريكي لقطع جزء من رحلته
الى المحيط الهادئ للمفاوضات مع
الجمهوريين عندما يعود في الغنم العربيه
واشنطن
اذا مشاهدينا تدرس خدمه صحه الوطنيه ان
اتش اس في انجلترا مجموعه من الاصلاحات
الجديده في نظام الرعايه الاوليه للتخفيف
من عدد المرضى على لوائح الانتظار حيث
سيتمكن ملايين المرضى من الحصول على وصفات
طبيه مباشره من الصيدليات بدلا من القطاع
من قطاع الطب العام ما يثير تساؤلات حول
الضغط الذي سيواجه صيدليات التي تعاني
بالاساس من نقص في الايد العامله
لا يخفى على الناس في بريطانيا ان القطاع
الصحي يمر بازمه شديده عده حلول طرحت من
اجل التخفيف من وطاتها كوضع مسؤوليه وصف
بعض الادويه على عاتق صيدليات كهذه فهل
ينتقل عبر الازمه الصحيه من المستشفيات
الى الصيدليات
طرحنا هذا السؤال على الصيدلي عمر زاهر
الذي يكاد يخلو يومه من ساعه راحه اذ يدخل
هذه الصيدليه ما لا يقل عن 100 شخص يوميا
واذا ما قمنا بعمليه حسابيه بسيطه نرى ان
عمليه صرف الادويه تستغرق ما بين عشر
دقائق الى نصف ساعه
وبالتالي المزيد من المسؤوليات والمزيد من
ساعات العمل والمزيد من الحاجه لايض عامل
جديده
كيف بدو يمشي هذا الموضوع كيف بدنا ننسق
بالوقت نحن اولريدي اوفر ستريتش يعني
مضغوطين كتير هل يا ترى في فان دينك وراح
يكون في مجال راح يكون فيه يعني لحتى
ينعمل له ينعمل هذا الموضوع بشكل صحيح بس
مثل ما بيقولوا
في بريطانيا ينتظر اكثر من سبعه ملايين
مريض موعدا مع طبيب لكن مع الخطه الجديده
تحاول الحكومه تمرير بعض اعباء نظام الصحه
الوطنيه الى الصيدليات فمريض الانفلونزا
مثلا بامكانه رؤيه الصيدلاني بدلا من
الطبيب العام
صيدليتك عندي عندما ساحه معينه يمكن ممكن
تاخدي جزء منها لتعمليه
مش مشكله بس التوظيف والتمرين صياد اللي
ما بيقدروا يتحملوه وهنا هو البيت الاصيل
هل يا ترى الدوله رح تقول له للصيدله لانه
انت عمول هذا الموضوع او هن راح يكون
عندهم التمويل لحتى يساعدونا فيه
والخمسه عشره مليون موعد طبي خلال العامين
المقبلين لكن البعض يرى ان هذه الخطه ترحل
الازمه من قطاع المستشفيات الى صيدليات من
لندن عروب عبد الحق العربيه
تفقد زعيم كوريا الشماليه اول قمر صناعي
للاستطلاع العسكري لبلاده ووافق على خطط
العمل المستقبليه للجنه التحضيريه لاطلاق
القمر ووفقا لما ذكرته وكاله الانباء
المركزيه الكوريه الرسميه جونغ اون اكد ان
على الطبيعه الاستراتيجيه بل اكد على
الطبيعه الاستراتيجيه لامتلاك اقمار
صناعيه للاستطلاع العسكري وقال ان لبلاده
الحق في الدفاع عن النفس ضد تصعيد واشنطن
اعلنت بكين ان سفينه صيد صينيه جنحت في
المحيط الهندي ما اسهر عن فقدان كامل
افراد طاقمها وعددهم 39 شخصا وقالت قناه
السي سي تي في تلفزيونيه الحكوميه انه حتى
الان لم يعثر على اي من المفقودين وهم
سبعه عشر صينيا و17 اندونيسيا وخمسه
فلبينيين مشيره الى ان الرئيس الصيني شوجن
امر على الفور باطلاق عمليه بحث وانقاذ
ايدت محكمه استئناف فرنسيه ادانه الرئيس
الفرنسي السابقوزي في قضيه فساد محكمه
الاستئناف الفرنسيه ايدت المنع المؤقت
لساركوزي مع شغل وظائف عام وكذلك حكمها
وكذا هي حكمها ايضا على الرئيس الفرنسي
السابق سركوزي لمده ثلاث سنوات اثنتان
منها مع وقف التنفيذ واضافت المحكمه في
قرارها ان الرئيس الفرنسي السابق سيضع
سوارا الكترونيا بدلا من احتجازه في السجن
رحب الى ماسك بمديره تويتر التنفيذيه
الجديده ليندا يا كارينو خلال اجتماع شركه
تسلا السنوي في اوستن واعتبر ان المنصه
الان في مكان مستقر
اظن ان تويتر الان في مكان مستقر ومن
الواضح انني متحمس جدا لانضمام ليندا
كارينو واعتقد انها ستقوم بعمل رائع في
اداره المنصه وبالطبع ساقدم المشهور بشان
اي تطوير تكنولوجي
ينطلق مهرجان كان هذا العام على خلفيه
اضطرابات في فرنسا استقرر تنظيم عدد من
الاحتجاجات بالقرب من قسم من قصد المهرجان
وسط الاجراءات امنيه مشدده مفرد العربيه
مشاهدينا الى كان سعد المسعودي وهذا
التقرير عن افتتاح المهرجان
انطلقت فعاليه مهرجان كان سينما الدولي
بدورته السادسه والسبعين بمشاركه نخبه من
نجوم السينما العالميه يتقدمهم الممثل
الامريكي جوني ديب الذي يشارك في فيلم
الافتتاح جند للمخرجه الفرنسيه وهو من
انتاج المملكه العربيه السعوديه وشركه
الانتاج الفرنسيه ثم قدم رئيس اللجنه
التحكيميه السويدي روباند الفائز بالسعف
الذهبيه للسنه الماضيه وقدم لجنته
التحكيميه ومن بينهم الممثله المغربيه
مريم توزاني وكرم المهرجان هذا العام
الممثل الامريكي مايكل دوجلاس وعرض مقاطع
من افلامه الشهيره وقدمت له الممثله
الايطاليه الفرنسيه كيارا مستر ياني عساف
الذهبيه
لاهالي كانوا المدن الفرنسيه اريد ان
اقبلكم من اعماق قلبي وشكرا جزيلا لكم
وداعا
ثم جاء دور الممثل الفرنسي التي اختار
المهرجان صورتها لتكون ملصقا رسميا لهذا
العام ثم تحدثت عن تضامنها مع اوكرانيا
وتحدثت ببعض كلمات اوكرانيه
افكر قبل كل شيء في اوكرانيا واتمنى كل
السعاده والحريه لهم ويبقى لدينا امل ثم
اعلنت بمعيه الممثل الامريكي دوجلاس عن
بدء المهرجان
[تصفيق]
وسيستقبل مهرجان كان السينما الدولي نجوم
السينما العالميه على مدى ايام المهرجان
وسيعرض نحو 100 فيلم من بينها 21 فيلما في
المسابقه الرسميه متعه المشاهده لافلام
كبار صناعه السينما العالميه في مهرجان
كان والذي يستمر حتى السابع والعشرين من
مايو الجاري وحضور اللافت للسينما العربيه
في المسابقات الرسميه سعد المسعود العربيه
مهرجان كان السينمائي بفرنسا والى
العناوين المشاهدين
عشرون ملفا يبحثون وزراء خارج العرب
ابرزها اعاده اعمار سوريا ووقف الحرب في
السودان
اوروبا تعتزم بناء تحالف تقوده بريطانيا
وهولندا لتزويد اوكرانيا بمقاتلات من طراز
بعد اقاله باشاغا واحالته للتحقيق
البرلمان الليبي يقول ان حكومته لم تفي
بالتعهدتها
وسط اطلاق نار كثيف قوات اسرائيليه تقتحم
مدينه الطوباس شمال الضفه واصابات بين
الفلسطينيين
كونوا بعافيه مشاهدينا
[موسيقى]
متابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات